il est 6h du matin les habitants donnent
encore une colonne de policiers avance
dans la nuit les commandos alcoon
s'apprêtent à entrer en action objectif
désarmer un gang qui contrôle tout le
quartier
[Musique]
ici on dit que les Mexicains descendent
des Aztèques les Péruviens des Incas et
les Argentins des bateaux
[Musique]
car c'est par Buenos Aires que des
millions de migrants venus d'Italie
d'Espagne de France de Russie ont foulé
le sol du Nouveau Monde
c'était il y a un siècle mais
aujourd'hui encore 60% de la population
et d'origine italienne et l'identité
européenne de cette mégalopole se
retrouve à chaque coin de rue
c'est café son architecture son mode de
vie fond de Buenos Aires la plus
européenne des capitales d'Amérique du
Sud
un métissage qui a donné naissance à
l'un des symboles de la ville le tango
moi je n'ai jamais mis les pieds à
Buenos Aires mais mon père il a grandi
ils m'ont l'a tellement parlé que cette
ville m'est familière
Buenos Aires a longtemps été une des
capitales les plus sûrs du continent
mais la crise de 2001 a fait basculer
des millions d'Argentins dans la
pauvreté et la violence c'est incrusté
en avril 2014 il a même fallu instaurer
l'état d'urgence
car la ville est gangrenée par un
phénomène sans précédent la délinquance
urbaine agression braquage à main crime
crapuleux explose
tout au long de mon séjour je vais voir
l'ombre des narcos plané sur la ville
[Musique]
je découvrirai les agressions brutales
que vivent quotidiennement les portagnos
comme on appelle ici les habitants de
Buenos Aires je patougrais avec une
police à la réputation plombée qui
s'efforce de racheter son image
j'espisterait un match de foot à aurisk
avec les maravas c'est où les Gan à la
sauce Argentine
un rescapé des griffes du Paco la drogue
des pauvres nous racontera son cauchemar
je rencontrerai des mères courage qui
luttent au péril de leur vie pour sortir
les enfants de la rue
un prêtre des bidonvilles menacé de mort
par les narcos m'accueillera dans sa
paroisse
enfin je vais revivre l'horreur des
années de dictature une violence d'État
que le pays ne parvient toujours pas à
digérer
bienvenue à Buenos Aires avec en poche
un passeport pour le crime
[Musique]
me voici donc en Argentine à Buenos
Aires la capitale
coincé entre la pampa et le Rio de la
Plata 13 millions de port kenyos vivent
ici le tiers de la population du pays
impossible de commencer ce périple sans
un détour par un quartier dont j'ai
beaucoup entendu parler direction
récolta au centre de Buenos Aires
au cinquième étage de cet immeuble des
fraischi une adresse très chère à ma
famille enfin à Jean-Pierre mon père
a vécu pendant presque 10 ans
avec ses parents
au cinquième étage donc au dernier étage
a priori 10 années qui ont marqué
l'enfance de mon père qui est même parlé
l'espagnol avant le français enfin
quasiment ça devait être chic à l'époque
la venue elle est un peu moins
une petite photo quand même pour mon
père
c'est bien qu'au bout d'un moment il y
avait des pleins de passants qui étaient
à couper en dessous pour voir les
acrobaties ce petit enfant pas très
obéissant
il y a toujours la corniche qui relie le
salon
[Musique]
mon père n'a gardé que de très bons
souvenirs ici mais ça c'était dans les
années 50 depuis le pays a enchaîné les
dictatures et les crises économiques et
la violence s'est installé lentement
[Musique]
parfois la capitale prend des allures de
ville siégé les différentes polices du
pays unis leur force ce dispositif
impressionnant et déployé pour un simple
match de foot ce jour-là mille flics
sont mobilisés
au pays du vieux Maradona l'amour du
foot est absolu presque une deuxième
religion mais il y a un gros problème
le foot argentin est pourri de
l'intérieur par des groupes mafieux de
fans ultra-violents les Barabas
[Applaudissements]
leur bilan fait froid dans le dos
45 morts et une centaine de blessés pour
les quatre dernières années une moyenne
de 11 morts par an
[Musique]
au cimetière d'avesnesda une banlieue du
sud de Buenos Aires j'ai rendez-vous
avec Nora son fils a été assassiné à la
sortie d'un stade voilà
le fils de Nora Christian avait 25 ans
c'était la première fois qu'il se
rendait un match de foot et parce qu'il
portait les couleurs des dépendante et
son équipe favorite il a reçu deux coups
de couteau dans le dos par un membre de
la barava de l'équipe adverse
et c'est un poème que lui a écrit une
amie
Nora se recueille deux fois par semaine
devant la tombe de son fils à chaque
fois c'est la même douleur Nora ce sont
démunis
je me sens abandonnée de tous abandonné
par l'État
j'ai l'impression que rien n'a été
résolu car le crime de mon fils est
resté impuni
après le drame n'aura tente de retrouver
les meurtriers et découvre alors que les
barabravas fonctionnent comme n'importe
quelle mafia
tout le monde sait qu'il assassin de son
fils mais personne n'a jamais été
inquiété
celui qui frappe Christian c'est l'un
des chefs de la Bara celui qui répartit
les places dans le stade et c'est un
autre type de cette baraque qui
poignardent mon fils quand il est à
terre de votre fils sont toujours en
liberté il y a pas eu de procès ils ont
été arrêtés
d'une protection politique car il était
un membre des Barras chargé de
distribuer les entrées et donc s'il
avait été inculpé il aurait impliqué les
dirigeants et les politiques ils ont
donc classé l'affaire sans suite et ce
crime est resté impuni comme à chaque
fois dans le foot argentin
des politiques et des juges mêlés à
cette violence l'accusation est à peine
croyable la violence des barrace exporte
bien au-delà des stades trafic extorsion
d'argent et complicité avec le pouvoir
sont les autres caractéristiques de ces
groupuscules
formes je décide d'aller voir Gustavo
grabia pas difficile à trouver il anime
tous les jours une émission de foot à la
radio
je suis sûr que Maïté sera très
attentive à ce joueur le monsieur muscle
du terrain je suis pas si fan que ça
mais tu viens de me dire que tu le
trouvais super
le domaine ce journaliste a enquêté
pendant des années sur les baravas et ce
qu'il a à me dire et tout simplement
sidérant
il chantait
d'argent avec cet argent ils peuvent
acheter beaucoup de gens dans les
quartiers populaires où ils habitent et
à force d'acheter des gens ils finissent
par avoir beaucoup d'influence
il deviennent des personnages importants
du quartier alors les politiques se
disent allons voir ce barrage qui
contrôle déjà beaucoup de gens et peut
nous avoir des votes ou faire le sale
boulot pour nous
à partir de là le pouvoir débarrasse a
grandi et c'est devenu le monstre que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui
à Buenos Aires cinq commissaires de
police sont actuellement jugés dans des
affaires en lien avec les Barras tous
incapables de justifier leur niveau de
vie
et l'influence des bars à bravas sur la
vie du club de s'arrête pas là
aujourd'hui Buenos Aires va vivre un
nouvel état de siège rétrograder l'année
dernière en deuxième division le club il
n'est pas Diane t joue sa remontée au
sein de l'élite un match à haut risque
pour la police
[Musique]
je retourne à aveyenneda la banlieue
pauvre d'Inde
les membres de la barade el Roro la
barabrava du club se sont donnés
rendez-vous
[Musique]
il est 9h du matin le match de
l'après-midi est encore loin mais les
fans sont déjà bien éméchés l'alcool
coule à flot et tout le monde en profite
ils sont tous bourrés là
la drogue est également très présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet homme se fait appeler pampa
c'est le chef ici
à notre micro il refuse d'évoquer le
fonctionnement de la barre à Brava et
préfère parler carnavals
[Musique]
du foot argentin c'est ça c'est ça
ce qui motive les supporters du club
c'est le carnaval l'amour du carnaval
rien d'autre aucun supporter dans le
monde n'a autant la passion du foot que
les Argentins
c'est pour ça que plein d'étrangers
viennent ici visiter les différents
stades du pays
dans tout le pays les baravas sont
organisés comme des gangs celle des
dépaniente n'échappe pas à la règle
pampa et l'un de leurs colonel il doit
obéir un général qui n'est pas ici et
qui gère les affaires de la Bara pampa
lui dirige ses jeunes les soldats
souvent des gamins pauvres qui trouvent
dans les Barras un échappatoire leur
mission mettre de l'ambiance dans le
stade avec notamment des chansons de
leur cru
[Applaudissements]
notre présence commence à déranger pampa
il nous demande d'arrêter de tourner le
chef de la barave distribuer des places
pour le match de précieux sésame qu'on
ne devrait trouver en principe qu'au
guichet du stade intrigué nous filmons
maintenant en caméra cachée
moi il m'en faut une tu en as déjà toi
toi tu en as pas tiens voilà à qui il en
manque un peu à l'écart un des soldats
de la Bara nous prend à partie
vous filmez le trafic de billets là non
je veux juste voir ce que tu filmes ça
pose un problème
[Musique]
la distribution des places en notre
présence a rendu pampa nerveux
montre-moi ce que tu as filmé
je regarde ici
je vois rien
va plus en arrière
mais pourquoi on peut pas filmer là
nous n'en serons pas davantage pour le
moment la distribution se termine la
tension retombe un peu nous rallumons la
caméra
[Applaudissements]
les barravas se déplacent toujours en
groupe c'est donc en car que la petite
troupe se rend au stade l'heure du match
approche les Barras exulte et font
monter l'ambiance d'un cran
pompom n'a pas averti son général de
notre tournage il nous débarque du car
avant d'arriver au stade je tente une
dernière fois de savoir d'où viennent
ces mystérieuses places sans succès
secret professionnel
[Musique]
de nombreux supporters n'ont pas eu de
place et tentent de passer en force
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'intérieur le match a commencé comme
prévu les supporters se lâchent ce coin
de tribune vide est la seule mesure
concrète prise contre la violence ces
dernières années les supporteurs de
l'équipe visiteuse sont désormais
interdits sur le terrain independiente
pas de but score final
les joueurs qui rapidement le terrain
sous les sifflets les projectiles et
sous bon escort le match sera rejoué
plus tard et l'Independiente sortira
vainqueur le club pourra remonter en
première division
[Musique]
l'année dernière pour la première fois
un homme a voulu mettre fin au pouvoir
de la barabrava de l'île des bandante
cet homme le voilà ainsi au centre de
l'image c'est Ravières Cantero le
président du club il a fait une promesse
mettre les chefs de la Bara à la porte
du stade et coupez le cordon financier
reliant la barre à Brava à la direction
du club ils viennent de lui lancer une
chaussure
[Applaudissements]
l'assemblée générale du club qui suit
cette annonce les mouvements ts les bars
à bravas qui se sont invités à la
Réunion s'en prennent violemment au
président qui doit quitter la salle dans
la précipitation
quelques semaines plus tard Javier
Cantero jette les ponts il démissionne
change de téléphone et refuse toute une
interview aujourd'hui il ne s'occupe
plus du tout de foot mais un garde du
corps veille toujours sur lui
[Musique]
au palais de la législature la Buenos
Aires j'ai retrouvé la responsable de la
sécurité du club sous la présidence de
Cantero
laurensia arietto participe à une
réunion avec des victimes de la violence
de foot
je retrouve Nora c'est un moment rare
pour ces familles d'habitude réduites au
silence
à la télé
c'est une honte
les nerfs
tous autour de la table ont perdu un
enfant dans un stade tous se sont
heurtés au silence et à la corruption de
la justice
je ne fais confiance ni au juge ni aux
avocats personne qui je vais croire ils
ont tué ma famille je me suis retrouvée
seule je dois lutter seul contre tous
alors qu'est-ce que je peux espérer
comment est-il possible que nous les
victimes nous devions passer le peu de
vie qu'il nous reste à découvrir les
horreurs du pouvoir judiciaire
tout ça les gens ne le voient pas le
pays ne le voit pas
les députés les sénateurs tous ces gens
qui vivent comme des grands seigneurs
ils ne le voit pas
on leur a assassiné un enfant à eux
est-ce qu'on aura assassiné un enfant
malgré les menaces de mort florentcia
s'est battues pour traduire en justice
les assassins mais selon elle la
corruption des policiers en lien avec
les barravas est un obstacle
insurmontable
si le délinquant débarrasse n'est jamais
condamné ce n'est pas parce que le délit
qu'il a commis est sophistiqué ou malin
il n'est jamais puni parce que quelqu'un
est payé pour nettoyer la scène du crime
et détruire l'épreuve c'est ça qui se
passe on s'est rendu compte que c'est au
cours de l'instruction dans les échanges
entre la police et le procureur que les
preuves sont altérés pour éviter la
condamnation des têtes pensantes
ces Florencia qui va me faire comprendre
pourquoi pampa ne voulait pas qu'on
filme son trafic de billets
sont donnés au club par la Fédération de
foot
l'extors
consiste à aller demander au club enfin
demandé disons plutôt exiger au moins
100 invitation pour les revendre et se
faire de l'argent à partir de quelque
chose qui est gratuit quand j'ai
découvert tout ça j'ai demandé à ce
qu'on contrôle ses billets et 10 jours
plus tard ils m'ont mis à la porte c'est
donc cette caisse noire qui n'est
contrôlé par personne qui finance en
partie les barasses mais alors ce sont
les barrasses qui sont les vrais patrons
du foot ici non non les barrages sont
les exécutants des dirigeants du foot en
Argentine et les dirigeants ce sont des
hommes politiques et des juges corrompus
qui utilisons tout impunité les Barras
pour faire du business car le foot
génère beaucoup d'argent ce qui est
utile quand on veut accéder au pouvoir
car être dirigeant de club sert souvent
de tremplin vers la politique ou la
justice
[Musique]
ainsi va le foot professionnel ici
maravas politique juge et fédération
continue d'entretenir des liens
sulfureux le nouveau président de l'Inde
est un syndicaliste proche des partis
politiques le maire de Buenos Aires et
l'ancien président de Boca Junior le
club de Maradona il n'a jamais rien fait
pour lutter contre la violence dans le
foot
j'aurais bien aimé entendre les juges
qui ont suivi ces affaires de violence
et de corruption mais visiblement
l'envie n'était pas partagée
en revanche une autre institution semble
vouloir jouer la transparence la police
métropolitaine Cray il y a 4 ans pour
nettoyer les rues de la capitale la
métropolitana a très envie de se faire
connaître et de se faire aimer et même
droit un guide francophone bonjour
[Musique]
un symptôme de la police
a très envie de me montrer un lieu
incontournable de la ville La Bocca
c'est un peu l'âme de Buenos Aires le
Montmartre argentin au 19e siècle
c'était le quartier canaille où
s'installer les immigrants espagnols et
italiens
cet ancien quartier ouvrier est
aujourd'hui très prisé des touristes du
monde entier
ça c'est des vrais méchants
mais Horacio ne va pas amener là pour
admirer les jolies façades colorées de
la Bocca ce quartier c'est sa victoire à
lui sur les délinquants en postant ces
hommes à chaque coin de rue il aurait
mis fin aux agressions
en bon soldat ces deux policiers vont me
le confirmer pour enlever vous les mains
des poches là vous êtes filmé il va vous
poser une question ou deux ça va c'est
cool il se passe rien non ça va c'est
calme
les gens nous disent qu'ils se sentent
beaucoup plus en sécurité dans la rue
quand il voit les policiers
moi aussi j'étais rassuré jusqu'à ce que
Horatio me présente mon nouvel ami
c'est pas que je veux faire peur loin de
là hein
voilà en fait c'est calme mais on a
quand même un homme armé avec nous avec
Jenny par balle et tout c'est le fichier
Martinez voilà voilà
mieux vaut prévenir que guérir et avant
on avait été confronté à quel genre de
délits
à l'arrache des sacs des équipes des
films assez
le problème c'est qu'à deux pâtés de
maisons de là la situation est loin
d'être stabilisée
ici plus un seul touriste dans la rue
et mon ange gardien Martinez ne me lâche
pas d'une semaine
bon là c'est un autre quartier de
l'avocat c'est toujours on est toujours
donc avant même un policier il venait
ici et on lui demander de partir je sais
pas si c'est
comme ça à 100% mais quand même ouais
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
aujourd'hui on peut voir qu'il y a des
voitures des polices de prévention
permanentes dans ce quartier ici à
l'abandon pendant des décennies même les
flics rasaient les murs et encore quand
ils osé y mettre les pieds
et voyez
sans commencer
à comprendre que ici c'est hors de
question de rester
pas trop de la rue de quartier c'est la
police métropolitaine qui a repris le
territoire c'est très simple tu as
repris le territoire
de guerre quand même
c'est l'obsession des nouveaux flics
argentins la reconquête des territoires
si la police a remporté une bataille à
La Bocca la guerre contre l'insécurité
et la violence à Buenos Aires est loin
d'être gagnée
ces derniers mois les vols à l'arracher
les braquages à ma armées ont augmenté
[Musique]
plus on s'éloigne du centre moins les
rues sont sûrs
je vais le vérifier avec une autre
police celle du Grand Buenos Aires la
monnaie NC
[Musique]
nous voici à l'anus juste au sud de la
capitale je suis à peine assis à
l'arrière de la voiture que les sirènes
se mettent à hurler une commerçante
vient de se faire braquer l'agresseur
était armée d'un couteau
[Musique]
deux patrouilles sont déjà sur place le
voleur un homme d'une trentaine d'années
qui tentait de s'enfuir à moto vient
d'être maîtrisé sa victime et sous le
choc
il est entré et il m'a demandé de
l'argent une fois à l'intérieur il m'a
dit je vais te tuer c'est tout ce qu'il
m'a dit
les policiers bombes le torse les
arrestations après un braquage sont
rares il faut dire que cette fois ils
ont eu plutôt de la chance
il a démarré sa moto mais elle a calé
du coup il est parti en poussant sa moto
on a appelé la police qu'il a intercepté
très vite
l'agresseur a beau avoir été arrêté ça
ne suffit pas à calmer les riverains
quand tu pars au boulot tu es pas sûr
d'y arriver vivant et le soir quand tu
rentres c'est la même chose
[Musique]
cette banlieue le commissaire Pilar la
connaît comme sa poche 23 ans qu'il
quadrille les faubourgs de Buenos Aires
on a deux personnes de sexe masculin je
ne connais pas l'âge pour l'instant
je sais qu'ils sont en possession de
stupéfiant il y aurait de la marijuana
et du Paco
le Paco c'est le crack local qui fait
des ravages à Buenos Aires ces deux
dealers ont été pris en flagrant délai
sur le capot leur marchandises vin dose
de Paco 100 g de marijuana
devant notre caméra les policiers vont
appliquer à la lettre une procédure pour
le moins surprenante il faut appel à un
passant cet homme à la casquette son
rôle observez que la fouille au corps se
déroule dans les règles l'objectif est
double d'abord prévenir les bavures
policières mais aussi les faux
témoignages des suspects
l'agent qui a procédé à l'arrestation va
maintenant les fouiller vas-y fouille
bien plus près comme ça tu verras mieux
toi tu n'as plus rien non non j'ai plus
rien
toi tu as quelque chose encore
une cachette qui n'a pas l'air de
surprendre les policiers qui poursuivent
la fouille toujours sous l'oeil du
témoin
l'homme caché là une dose de Paco elle
est présentée au témoin qui devra
certifier au commissariat ce qu'il a vu
pendant des années la police était
infestée de ripoux il fallait faire le
ménage le commissaire Pilar approuve
cette mesure mais reconnaît que son
application peut tourner au casse-tête
il y a des gens qui ne veulent pas
collaborer mais pourquoi c'est une perte
de temps pour eux ils ont peur
non non enfin ça dépend des zones quand
on a pas de témoin ou s'ils veulent pas
collaborer on fait un rapport à la
justice pour expliquer pourquoi on a dû
agir sans témoin
c'est bientôt le week-end et pour la
police de Buenos Aires vendredi ça rime
avec saisie
5 blocs plus loin les flics ont mis la
main sur d'autres revendeurs dans leurs
poches toujours les mêmes substances
mets un coup de couteau pour qu'on voit
ce que c'est
de la marijuana compactée et encore du
Paco comme tout à l'heure
ces boules noires intriguent les
policiers
ouvre-moi ça
finalement il ne s'agit que de balles de
tennis entourés de scotch destinés aux
jonglage
ces deux suspects sont mineurs en
Argentine 7 jeunes sur dix vivent dans
la précarité
une aubaine pour les narcos qui trouvent
la main d'oeuvre bon marché et
consommateurs
tu vois la couleur du paco est plus
sombre que celle de la cocaïne attends
je vais lui demander combien il paye
cette rôle
7 euros
la parfaite combinaison
se termine avec cloud ils deviennent
esclave de leur addiction deviennent
délinquants pour trouver l'argent et
acheter leur Paco
[Musique]
le paco est une drogue redoutable c'est
le fléau numéro 1 à Buenos Aires
cette drogue est très addictive et bon
marché elle apparaît au lendemain de la
crise de 2001 l'Argentine est sur la
paille la consommation de Paco explose
en 4 ans elle augmente de 200%
reste de cocaïne kérosène morsera ce pot
pourri extrêmement toxique détruit le
système nerveux
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le paco est partout dans les
rues de Buenos Aires comme ici dans le
quartier de Barakas au sud de la ville
on les appelle les zombies le
comportement convulsif le regard vide
ils avancent comme des morts-vivants
tout en gémissant
cet homme filmait en caméra amateur dans
le quartier de constitutionne au cœur de
Buenos Aires paraît totalement aligné
le conducteur de cette voiture s'arrête
un instant mais préfère repartir
laissant le junkie à son sort
[Applaudissements]
ces images m'ont bouleversé
j'ai voulu rencontrer un rescapé et ils
sont plutôt rares généralement on ne
sort pas vivant d'une addiction au Paco
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Hugo repero est photographe
indépendant
allez encore une autre
il vit de petits shootings des photos
qui n'arrivent pas toujours à vendre
mais tes jambes sur le banc là pour voir
mais dans les années 90 Hugo au Pérou
faisait la pluie beau temps à Buenos
Aires c'était le directeur photo de
noticias le plus grand magazine culturel
d'Argentine le jour il photographier des
célébrités la nuit il s'encanaillait
comment tu vas
pardon de vous déranger en plein travail
aujourd'hui on se rend compte parce que
vous avez traversé une pilote très
difficile avec le Paco
en fait j'ai toujours été en contact
avec les drogues et le monde de la photo
de la fête de la mode
on dit toujours qu'on peut contrôler une
ligne de coque par-ci un joint par là
c'est soft
mais quand je suis tombé sur cette
drogue le Paco ça m'a tué c'est terrible
ça ça m'a retourné la tête ça m'a rendu
fou j'ai fini à l'asile un vrai
cauchemar
Hugo tombe dans le piège après le décès
d'un proche il est en pleine dépression
vulnérable et se laisse tenter par la
cigarette de Paco tendue par une jolie
junkie
qu'est-ce que ça fait de fumer
une sensation très courte très brève
ça dure deux ou trois minutes
on pourrait dire que c'est comme un
orgasme
tu perds totalement la notion de là où
tu te trouves
tout est distordu tu entends
différemment comme si tu étais sous
l'eau
et après tu es très nerveux électrique
tu es en âge
tu deviens complètement parano tu crois
qu'on espionne par la fenêtre et c'est
là que tu as besoin d'une autre dose
voilà c'est comme ça
aujourd'hui Hugo a retrouvé le sourire
mais le cauchemar a duré 3 ans un jour
je suis sorti avec un bâton et je suis
allé tout péter chez le voisin d'en face
parce que je croyais qu'il m'espionait
j'ai arraché le pied d'une table et je
suis allé tout fracasser dans sa maison
c'est là que j'ai fini en camisole de
force
comment comment vous en êtes sortis à
quel moment on se dit faut que j'arrête
tout ça il faut que je m'en sorte et
nous là c'est maintenant une semaine
j'ai eu deux accidents de voiture sous
l'emprise du Paco c'était une voiture
neuve que j'ai totalement détruite
et au deuxième accident je me suis cassé
la mâchoire j'ai perdu mes dents j'avais
le visage complètement fracassé et
intensé je me suis regardé dans le
miroir et là je me suis dit je ne veux
plus être cet homme là
Hugo s'inscrit alors à un programme de
désintox dans un hôpital
c'était il y a 8 ans l'ex photographe de
star n'a pas rejeté depuis
pourtant la tentation n'est jamais loin
comme ici à la constitution
souvenez-vous le quartier où était filmé
l'homme sous l'emprise du Paco
j'ai rendez-vous avec un autre ext
toxico il consacre sa vie à lutter
contre la drogue c'est pratique il
habite dans Constitution
me reçoit donc chez lui sa maison
ressemble à un joyeux casharnaüm mais il
ne faut pas s'y tromper c'est le siège
de sa très influente
ongles narcotrafic dans toute
l'Argentine
Claudius s'est fait connaître en
dévoilant les failles du contrôle de
l'espace aérien argentin et en dénonçant
la passivité des autorités pour les
avions des narcotrafiquants la voie est
libre
la norme ici tu as la liste des 141
pistes d'atterrissage illégales du nord
du pays
c'est un document confidentiel de
l'armée de l'air
ce journal a fait une double page sur
les pistes clandestines et sur le
sitting que nous avons fait dans le
tchaco sur une de ses pistes
sur une piste illégale utilisée par des
marques trafiquants et il l'a envoyé ni
police ni juge ni procureur
et ces pistes continuent d'être
utilisées aujourd'hui encore en toute
impunité
selon Claudio l'Argentine est devenu la
plaque tournante de la cocaïne à
destination de l'Europe la poudre
blanche traverse l'Atlantique mais son
résidus le Paco reste au pays et
inondent les rues de la capitale allez
on y va
petite démonstration dans le quartier de
Claudio visite guidée
par la police malgré plus de 100
plaintes
c'est là où il y a cette femme bonjour
voilà l'endroit
il y a un point de vente de drogue
tiens le resto bar bien sombre là ça
s'en est un autre
se disputent leur territoire
c'est un des points de vente les plus
importants de constitutions
regarde ça ça c'est la réalité les flics
passent devant un lieu de vente sans que
personne ne fasse ou ne dise rien
[Musique]
Claudio est révolté malgré les
nombreuses plaintes des voisins les
trafiquants ont toujours pignon sur rue
cet immeuble squatté par les dealers
abritaient un lieu de production et de
consommation s'il n'est plus actif
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas grâce à la
police la force les policiers n'ont
jamais rien fait contre ce lieu jusqu'à
ce que la cuisine où était fabriquée la
cocaïne explose et que l'immeuble entier
prenne feu
commercialisation de Paco a été
totalement détruite c'est plus grâce à
Dieu qu'à la police ou au juge et
pourtant ils avaient reçu au moins 500
plaintes contre cet endroit
imaginez un peu 30 ou 40 types qui
entrent dans cette maison chaque nuit
avec des objets volés pour les échanger
contre de la drogue
il consommait le Paco là-dedans alors
imaginez ce que ça pouvait être pour le
voisinage qui cherchait désespérément
une aide qui n'est jamais venue
et le prix du Paco n'arrange rien à
moins de 1 euro la dose on l'appelle la
drogue des pauvres c'est donc à
l'intérieur et autour des bidonvilles
qu'on la retrouve massivement dans
certains quartiers 80% des jeunes en
serait dépendantes
[Musique]
j'ai rendez-vous avec des combattants
Martha et Célia sont les patrons de
l'ONG les maires en lutte contre le Paco
bonjour Martin bonjour comment ça va
je suis accueilli par des soldats à
l'intérieur la maison est en chantier et
j'apprends que les narcos sont venus
saccager les lieux il y a moins de 2
mois un message très clair adressé à
Martha et Célia
vous êtes engagé pour protéger les
enfants contre le Paco qui un fléau en
Argentine et vous êtes tellement investi
que les narcos sont venus ici et ont
tout cassé comment ça s'est passé
c'est sûrement parce qu'on a fait du bon
boulot qu'ils sont venus tout saccager
c'est vraiment pas cool mais bon c'est
comme ça
sur le coup c'est vrai qu'on a été un
peu démoralisé
c'est Célia qui a découvert les dégâts
ils ont cassé le cadenas et la chaîne
ou casser toutes les vitres ils ont volé
les 12 ordinateurs qu'on venait juste de
recevoir
ils ont cassé toute la salle de bain la
porte là ils ont emporté un grand frigo
la cuisinière même les lumières ils ont
coupé les câbles tout tout tout
d'autres auraient eu peur et se répartis
mais ça ça n'arrivera pas avec nous et
encore moins avec moi
le combat continue mais sous bonne
escort le local des mers en lutte contre
le Paco et désormais gardé en permanence
par trois gendarmes
et mère qui travaille ici ont toutes des
enfants qui fument du Paco quand Célia a
découvert que les siens étaient tombés
dedans il était déjà trop tard
et l'agression c'est surtout
l'agressivité ma fille m'a frappé deux
fois mon fils est très agressif il
m'insulte tout le temps ils sont paumés
ils perdent du poids ils perdent leur
faculté mentale
ils ont des tremblements dans tout le
corps il bouge sans cesse
pour acheter leur dose mes enfants ont
tout vendu dans la maison tout il ne me
reste plus rien même les habits
n'importe quoi les chaussures ils
vendent tout consommé
et ouais non et voilà où on en est on
continue la lutte pour voir comment
libérer nos enfants de ce fléau
car cette drogue te mène droit dans la
tombe
[Musique]
impossible pour ces mères de laisser
leurs enfants se transformer en
mort-vivant et pour cela elles ont leur
méthode
occuper le terrain ou le Paco prospère
les bidonvilles
[Musique]
bienvenue à la 31
un immense bidonville au cœur de Buenos
Aires 30
[Musique]
000 personnes vivent ici coincées entre
la voie ferrée et la récolta un quartier
chic de la capitale
c'est dans ce dédale de ruelles que je
retrouve Martin
deux fois par semaine elle va à la
rencontre des jeunes accros et de leur
mère pas de gendarmes avec elle
aujourd'hui seulement Lorena qui
appartient à l'association et habite à
la
c'était un magasin maintenant il loue
des chambres
des nos premiers pas des affiches d'une
fille disparue et d'une autre assassinée
donne le ton
nous tournons en caméra discrète
cet habitant de la veste jaune est
dépassée elle ne sait plus quoi faire
pour aider son fils accro aux Paco elle
demande de l'aide à Martin
je vais construire une cellule dans ma
maison avec des grilles et je vais
enfermer mon fils dedans je ferai venir
un infirmier mon fils va rester avec moi
parce que dans le dernier centre de
désintox il a été violé quoi elle dit
que son fils a été violée
pour Martin il faut agir vite le fils de
cette femme subit des violences
sexuelles et passe aujourd'hui le plus
clair de son temps dans la rue livré au
narcotrafiquants
dans les prochains jours on va se réunir
et prendre les choses en main il va y
avoir l'assistante sociale et l'avocate
et on s'occupera de tout ça ok
aujourd'hui plus que jamais il faut voir
comment l'aider à sortir son fils de la
rue parce qu'en ce moment il ne rentre
plus à la maison et dehors tu trouves de
tout tu as même pas besoin d'acheter de
la drogue il te l'offre
comme ça avec cette dette il t'oblige
toi à la vendre pour que tu leur
rembourses ta propre drogue un truc de
fou
[Musique]
mais dans la Visa 31 il y a encore des
quartiers entiers aux mains des dealers
facile à connaître ils sont délimités
par de surprenantes
ça veut dire qu'on entre dans une zone
libre ou tu peux acheter et te droguer
sans être embêté
mais c'est comme ça partout
cette zone libre est à moins de 100
mètres de ce petit commissariat
les mers dénoncent la complicité de
certains policiers sans grands résultats
les policiers laissent les narcos
tranquille
bien entendu contre de l'argent il
s'entendent entre eux et après il
n'oublie pas de venir chercher leur
commission
[Musique]
ont un seul refuge ce petit foyer mais
peuvent se laver se reposer
ceux qui viennent ici veulent s'en
sortir Lorena et Martha savent que c'est
à ce moment-là qu'ils sont le plus
fragiles
[Musique]
plutôt que de leur mettre la pression
elles sont d'abord à l'écoute
[Musique]
tu aimerais que ta maman s'occupe de toi
comme ça
oui j'aurais surtout aimé qu'elle est un
peu plus de cœur
mon frère jumeau a été tué il y a 8 mois
j'ai tout perdu
et comment ils l'ont tué
il était allé voler un truc et on l'a
tué on vivait dans la rue et on volait
pour survivre
mais bon il est mort
mais ça fait du bien de savoir qu'il y a
des gens qui ont envie de t'aider
comme ça tu pourras aider les autres à
ton tour
seulement voilà le Paco ne ravage pas
que la Bija 31
il gangrène tout la dose misère qui
ceinture le grand bonus air
les opérations policières aussi
spectaculaires qu'elles soient ni change
pas grand chose
mon voyage est loin d'être terminé
je dois encore m'aventurer dans les
bidons villes ravagés par la violence
j'ai rencontré le padre pépé un prêtre
qui ose défier les narcos
je serai initiée mes dépenses aux
techniques de close-combat
j'aurai le privilège d'être invité dans
un domaine ultra sécurisé
et je verrai comment les horreurs du
passé ressurgissent aujourd'hui
[Musique]
un drone de la police de Buenos Aires
s'élève au-dessus de la carcova
un gigantesque bidonville
il est 6h du matin les habitants donnent
encore
une colonne de policiers avance dans la
nuit les commandos alcool s'apprêtent à
entrer en action objectif
désarmer un gang qui contrôle tout le
quartier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
5 minutes plus tard deux hommes sont
maîtrisés et arrêtés
l'un d'entre eux et le frère du chef de
gang qui lui est toujours en fuite
des pistolets des fusils à pompe et une
centaine de ballots de cocaïne et de
Paco sont saisis
[Applaudissements]
ce sont des riverains excédés qui ont
alerté la police les narcos les avaient
délogés de leur maison pour installer
leurs points de vente
le jour s'est levé le bidonville se
dévoile
je décide d'aller à la Carva je
m'aperçois que ce bidonville a poussé
sur une décharge publique il est
traversé par le rio reconquête l'un des
plus pollués d'Argentine
redoutable pour ces conditions de vie la
carcova est aussi un coupe-gorge les
affrontants meurtriers entre band rival
sont menées courante
en temps normal il me serait impossible
de marcher seul ici c'est un territoire
hostile pour un étranger comme moi
et narcos ne me laisseraient pas faire
un pas
mais cette fois les trafiquants se
cachent et la rue appartient aux enfants
le temps d'une journée la carcova est en
fait
[Musique]
ce petit miracle on le doit à un homme
le très populaire pas de rété
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez courir tout de suite
[Musique]
je veux que vous sachiez que le t-shirt
que vous portez est un cadeau qui vous
restera comme souvenir pour ceux qui ont
couru pour la paix
c'est pour ça que le plus important ce
n'est pas d'arriver premier c'est juste
de participer au marathon pour la paix
à 52 ans le padre pépé et le symbole
argentin de la résistance au crime
organisé plusieurs fois menacées de mort
par les narcos pas de répéter a dû fuir
Buenos Aires pour se faire oublier
quatre ans plus tard il est de retour il
refuse catégoriquement de nous parler de
ses ennemis mais aujourd'hui il organise
un marathon pour la paix un message
clair destiné au trafiquant touché pas
aux enfants
on avait aujourd'hui des enfants avec un
beau sourire sur le visage je pense que
pour vous c'est important quand même
on a construit des paroisses pour faire
ressortir le meilleur des gens de la
Visa
pour éviter que le mal ne s'installe
et il y a beaucoup de bonté chez les
gens d'ici
[Musique]
ça va être une tâche difficile on vient
juste de commencer mais on a confiance
on voit que le rôle de l'Église est très
important dans le Bario mais que fait
l'état et Mario ce sont des quartiers
qui ont été abandonnés pendant des
décennies
pendant 40 ou 50 ans
sans égout sans revêtement sans
électricité sans école
et donc l'impact de tout ça est immense
aujourd'hui dans toutes ses populations
[Musique]
donc l'église est importante car très
souvent elle remplace l'État
pour pas de répéter
œuvrer dans les bidonville est une
vocation à toute épreuve
avant lui aucun prêtre ne s'était
préoccupé de la corva
à chaque sortie il est accueillant
Rockstar et les habitants ne boudent pas
leur plaisir
[Musique]
votre enfant était baptisé par le padre
oui pas de répéter c'est celui qui
arrive à tout faire
il nous rassemble tous il réalise les
vœux et les rêves des enfants
ça fait plus de 20 ans que padre pépé
veille sur les bidonvilles une mission
que lui a confié l'ancienne archevêque
de Buenos Aires Roro et Mario bergolio
plus connu aujourd'hui sous le nom de
Pape François
d'ailleurs le souverainif a invité son
protégé des bidonville au Vatican à
l'été 2013 entre les deux hommes il n'y
a qu'un point de discorde et oui encore
lui le foot
le pape est un supporter de San Lorenzo
et moi de Huracan ce sont deux équipes
rivales et opposées et sur ce point il
n'y a pas de réconciliation possible
[Musique]
c'est une journée de fête mais qui doit
pas masquer la réalité même si
aujourd'hui tout le monde a l'air
content heureux il reste beaucoup
beaucoup de travail à faire et on sent
bien que le danger est quand même
permanent et que le drame de la drogue
et du Paco et la violence en général et
loin d'être loin d'être éradiqué des
quartiers populaires en Argentine
pourtant il y a urgence
la violence liée à la drogue et l'une
des principales causes de mortalité chez
les jeunes
je retrouve le commissaire Pilar à
l'anus au sud de Buenos Aires
la nuit tombe pour la police tout
s'accélère
fait fureur dans les rues de Buenos
Aires en ce moment c'est le cardiaking
le vol de voiture avec violence
cette famille est encore sous le choc la
mère et sa fille de 7 ans rentrait la
voiture dans la cour quand deux hommes
armés ont surgi ils les ont jetés à
terre avant de repartir avec le véhicule
elles ont eu super peur vous voulez que
j'envoie un collègue pour vous amener au
commissariat non non j'attends que les
enfants se calment j'irai après avec ma
femme
traumatisé la famille n'y rapportait
plein de que le lendemain
après le cardiaking le Home jacquing
c'est l'autre cauchemar des portaignons
la crise aidant les cambriolages
explosent et la plupart en présence des
propriétaires en 2013 dans le grand
Buenos Aires 171 personnes ont été tuées
à bout portant devant ou à l'intérieur
de leur maison
quelqu'un est entré dans le domicile de
la personne qui a appelé elle a réussi à
s'échapper mais il y aurait encore sa
famille à l'intérieur
[Musique]
deux minutes plus tard le commissaire
est sur place il évitera assuré il ne
s'agit que d'un vol de voiture
je suis parti en courant et j'ai appelé
le 911 mais je ne savais pas bien si les
voleurs étaient encore dans la maison ou
pas
cet homme c'est un peu précipité en
décrivant le délit à un moment de
panique apparemment justifié dans le
quartier
à n'importe il se foutent de tout ça
peut tomber sur une femme un enfant tout
le monde là par exemple la fille d'en
face il y a un mois ils l'ont attaqué en
pleine après-midi ma mère était là
dehors mon frère était juste là moi
j'étais au balcon et un type comme si de
rien n'était à arraché son sac la pauvre
elle est tombée et elle s'est blessée
mais il s'en foutait qu'on soit là
cette voisine vit barricader
tu trouves ça normal qu'on vive comme ça
elle a installé ses grilles l'année
dernière pour se protéger
c'est un désastre c'est tous les jours
on ne peut pas vivre comme ça
ce soir là les victimes de la violence
ordinaire n'ont pas fini de créer leur
album
ici une bagarre de rue a fait sortir
tout le quartier cette fois la victime
sentir avec une gueule cassée pas de
blessé grave une bonne nouvelle pour le
commissaire Pilar qui sait que ce genre
de situation peut vite dégénérer
un peu plus loin deux voitures ont été
fracturées et dévalisés
je me rends compte que j'avais laissé
mon blouson bleu par exemple
un peu blasé la victime fait la liste
des objets volés avec les hommes du
commissaire Pilar
dans la rue d'à côté les policiers ont
arrêté les malfaiteurs
ça c'est mon porte-clé mais j'ai juste
besoin des clés
problème le porte-clé était récupéré
mais sans les clés exaspéré la victime
ne peut pas rentrer chez elle
allez rends-moi mes clés
de quelle clé tu parles pauvre con
emmène-le dans l'autre voiture là
j'habite au coin de la rue tu vas te
faire buter tu vas te faire buter
mais enfin tu avais mon porte-clé
prends-moi les clés arrête tes menaces
là sinon je vais t'incruster tout le
code pénal sur la tronche
inscrit les menaces là qu'il vient de
proférer
agression vol intimidation et menace
c'est le quotidien de ses habitants
l'autre victime est sous le choc non
désolé les gars je ne peux pas parler
l'homme à la casquette lui devra trouver
un gîte pour la nuit
ils ont pris mes clés les clés de chez
ma mère je sais pas comment je vais
rentrer chez moi ils les ont jeté par
ici j'en ai aucune idée ils ont juste
garder mon porte-clé ça ils l'ont bien
aimé mon porte-clé c'est comme ça que
j'ai su que c'était eux s'ils avaient
pas eu mon porte-clé sur eux j'aurais
rien pu dire tu leur demandes gentiment
tes clés et il te menace
et en plus je sais pas s'ils ont
l'adresse de chez moi c'est ça le
problème
Buenos Aires la situation se dégrade
dangereusement
l'insécurité devient la principale
préoccupation des habitants
novembre 2012
l'exaspération des portaignons s'affiche
dans les rues de la capitale
les médias parlent de centaines de
milliers de manifestants ils sont venus
dénoncer un état qui n'assure plus leur
protection mais le gouvernement de
Christina Kirchner fait la sourde
oreille
face à la passivité des autorités
certains habitants se prennent en main
je me rends chez Nelson à récolta le
quartier chic de Buenos Aires c'est le
président des associations de quartiers
de toute la ville aujourd'hui il a réuni
ses collègues pour apporter la dernière
touche à l'œuvre commune la carte des
crimes et délits de Buenos Aires
avec violence ou avec armes sont les
points marrons tu vois ça a beaucoup
augmenté dans ton arrondissement car là
et puis la vente de drogue a aussi
augmenté dans la zone 8
chaque association de voisins enregistre
elle-même les actes de violence commis
dans sa zone toute la ville est touchée
même les beaux quartiers au total 23000
crimes et délits sur un an sont
représentés sur ce plan à peine 4%
d'entre eux seulement ont été suivis
d'une plainte les chiffres officiels
seraient donc loin de la vérité c'est
essentiellement pour montrer une réalité
que les chiffres officiels ne reflètent
pas
qu'il transforme les chiffres mais parce
que les gens ne portent pas plainte et
les gens ne portent pas plainte pour
deux raisons essentiellement d'abord
parce qu'ils n'ont pas confiance dans la
police ils pensent que les policiers ne
font pas correctement leurs enquêtes
voire même qu'il existe des zones de
non-droit
la deuxième chose c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
confiance en la justice
ils pensent que si le délinquant est
arrêté non seulement la police ne
récupérera pas les objets volés mais
qu'en plus ils auront passé plus de
temps à porter plainte que le délinquant
n'en passera en détention
pour le portelnau les rues de la ville
sont de moins en moins sûr Nelson veut
nous en faire la démonstration au pied
de son immeuble
nous parcourons avec lui un seul paquet
de maison
était local dans ce magasin il y a eu
une attaque à main armée le mois dernier
fois là ils sont rentrés alors que
c'était plein de monde ici ils sont
rentrés avec une arme et ils ont frappé
l'employé
à côté là dans ce parking un homme a été
poursuivi jusqu'au dernier étage ils lui
ont tiré dessus pour lui voler son
argent
et cette pharmacie il y a peu de temps
ils ont cassé la vitrine pour rentrer et
ils ont dévalisé le magasin
on en a déjà vu un deux trois quatre six
commerces avec celui-ci ça fait 7 et 8
si on traverse la rue
sur les nerfs excéder certains habitants
vont basculer eux-mêmes dans la violence
[Musique]
nous revenons sur les différents cas de
lynchage on vous rappelle que ces
événements se propagent Rosario Cordoba
Rio
le pays est en pro à une vague de
lynchage le phénomène a pris racine à
300 km de Buenos Aires
[Musique]
la Seine se déroule en plein jour à
Rosario à les filmer avec un téléphone
portable
vient de voler le sac d'une femme voisin
passant chauffeur de taxi tout le monde
s'y met
les coups sont de plus en plus forts et
portés à la tête
le délinquant meurt trois jours plus
tard des suites de ses blessures il
avait 18 ans
depuis la médiatisation de ce crime les
lynchages gagne Buenos Aires la
détermination des habitants excédé se
lit même sur les murs de la capitale
[Musique]
en quelques jours les vengeances
collectives plus brutales les unes que
les autres ont lieu contre le
délinquants pris en flagrant délit
ici un homme arrache la sacoche d'un
retraité dans les rues d'un quartier
chic le voleur est volontairement fauché
par une voiture
puis les passants le haut de cou la
justice version Buenos Aires
[Musique]
cette fois le malfaiteur a eu de la
chance en arrêtant la police lui a sauvé
la vie
il aura fallu 12 lynchages dans la
capitale pour que les autorités
réagissent
le 5 avril 2014 Daniel Scioli le
gouverneur de la province de Buenos
Aires décrète l'état d'urgence pour un
an
je veux m'adresser au peuple qui souffre
de l'attaque cruel et sauvage d'une
délinquance
capable d'une violence sans précédent
une violence qui demande des réponses
adaptées de l'État
visiblement cette fois les autorités ont
entendu la détresse de la rue
l'état d'urgence décrété par le
gouverneur de Buenos Aires repose sur
trois mesures phares 50 millions d'euros
pour moderniser l'équipement de la
police
user jusqu'à la corde le rappel de 5000
flics retraités et la création d'une
unité de lutte contre le narcotrafic
c'est donc dans la plus grande école de
police du pays au sud de Buenos Aires
que je vais aller observer la mise en
place de ce plan de sauvetage je sais
que les flics argentins traînent une
très mauvaise réputation tortionnaire
raquetteur corrompu les portagnos n'ont
plus confiance dès mon arrivée on tient
d'ailleurs à me rassurer ici les
nouveaux flics seraient irréprochables
généralement lorsqu'ils entrent dans la
police ils ont au moins le bac c'est le
minimum
judiciaire surtout pénal une fois admis
leur formation va durer de 1 à 2 ans
alors là on a une arme de calibre
combien 9 mm ok
il possède un système de sécurité
interne pour éviter les accidents
est-ce que pour autant ça en fait un
système fiable à 100 %
non pourquoi parce que c'est un système
mécanique et que comme tout système
mécanique il peut s'enrayer
pendant leur formation les élèves ont
deux exercices de tir par semaine à
chaque séance ils utilisent 40
cartouches
[Musique]
la police argentine utilise des revolver
autrichiens
allez on avance mets-toi à gauche sont
exposés
et il s'en raye
couvre-toi pendant que tu restes ton
problème
allez on se retourne on y va
bon ton arme s'est enrrayé trop souvent
et ça c'est parce qu'elle n'a pas été
assez lubrifiée
donc si je tire et qu'il y a un problème
je me mets rapidement couvert et je
règle le problème aucun
n'hésitez pas à changer de main comme ça
vous tirez sous deux angles différents
est-ce qu'on se prépare
psychologiquement à faire l'usage de son
arme et éventuellement à tuer quelqu'un
à l'école les instructeurs nous
préparent à toutes les situations
donc on apprend et on sait qu'un jour ou
l'autre on tombera sur des situations à
risque mais au moment
l'idée bien sûr c'est de neutraliser
mais parfois les conséquences d'une
confrontation ça peut être la mort c'est
parfaitement
malgré le danger les écoles de police
n'ont jamais connu un telengouement dans
la seule province de Buenos Aires 26000
candidats ont postulé cette année un
record et une conséquence directe de
l'état d'urgence
l'école où je me trouve à accueilli 10
000 élèves au lieu des 4000 habituels
pour attirer les jeunes recrues le
gouverneur de Buenos Aires a fait mouche
en doublant les salaires un policier
touche désormais 800 euros par mois
lorsqu'on va faire là
l'extraire de son environnement
l'immobiliser le menotté et s'il est
armé le désarmé l'arrêter
ils savent pas ce qu'ils vont rencontrer
et moi je ne savais pas que le
commissaire allait me faire jouer le
rôle du
suspects
je regarde bien que l'armée vide je
remets le chargeur et je relâche le
percuteur et tu peux l'utiliser
je la cache
bon on est censé être dans un dans un
bidonville j'ai caché dans mon dos une
arme
et les policiers vont arriver pour
m'interpeller j'espère pas trop fier
l'amour
plus bas attention au passage
mais il est où toi
normalement les délinquants comprennent
l'espagnol évidemment
marche en arrière
les opérations spéciales c'est un peu le
rêve de ces jeunes policiers cela
viennent d'arriver ils seront officiers
dans deux ans
[Rires]
bon j'avais jamais été arrêté dans ma
vie il a fallu attendre Buenos Aires bon
c'est évidemment impressionnant surtout
quand on sait qu'on a rien fait mais ce
qui est très très étonnant c'est la
fermeté l'arrestation c'est avec les
gestes ils sont précis quand on vous
fouille on vous fouille pas comme à
l'aéroport mollement tout est très
direct très franc et très ferme voilà
c'est pas violent mais c'est très ferme
et je n'ai encore rien vu les meilleurs
recrues rejoindront les troupes d'élite
comme le fameux commando alcool
et quand on intervient en zone sensible
on a intérêt à maîtriser les techniques
du corps à corps le close-combat
je suis le délinquant du jour qu'il faut
maîtriser
là je pensais que la clé de bras était
bien réussi ce n'est visiblement pas la
vie de l'instructeur qui en remet une
couche ou une louche je sais pas
voilà voilà c'est bon parfait merci
super merci
[Rires]
[Musique]
je laisse les jeunes recrues à leur
apprentissage mon corps légèrement
doloré me dit qu'ils sont sur la bonne
voie le problème c'est qu'il
n'arriveront pas dans les rues de la
capitale avant deux ans
ceux qui en ont les moyens ont misé
depuis longtemps sur la sécurité privée
pour échapper à la violence les riches
vivent entre eux ils se réfugient dans
des quartiers résidentiels hyper
sécurisés des barrioches privados comme
celui-ci
ces quartiers fermés se sont multipliés
ces dernières années il en existait une
vingtaine dans les années 80 aujourd'hui
il y en a plus de 600
ce matin je décide de fuir le tumulte de
la capitale direction canuelas une
commune rurale à une heure de route
[Musique]
en chemin j'aperçois de nombreuses
propriétés protégées par des grillages
nous arrivons à chakras de la Trinidad
les fermes de la Trinité comme chaque
Barrio privado il y a un protocole
d'entrée très précis
bonjour bonjour vous avez vos papiers
pour le registre
l'endroit est totalement fermé et sous
la surveillance de garde le contrôle des
visiteurs mais aussi des habitants et
systématique
je suis invité par Mariano un porteuna
de la haute société le voilà au volant
du pick-up aux couleurs de son
entreprise
Salut bonjour
ça va bien vous parlez français oui un
peu
Mariano a 41 ans c'est un avocat
d'affaires qui a fait fortune dans la
finance pour lui le Barrio privado est
une nécessité
les Ferrières
il y a des gardes qui contrôlent les
entrées et qui font des patrouilles dans
la propriété toutes les heures
l'allée de la propriété fait tout de
même un peu plus d'un kilomètre ce
Barrio privado en pleine pampa n'abri
que quelques maisons de campagne sur des
dizaines d'hectares
nous arrivons chez Mariano
j'ai de la chance le businessman est un
bon vivant
ça c'est le vin de la famille il a prévu
pour le repas un barbecue c'est son
frère qui s'y colle enfin ici vous dites
surtout pas barbecue
ici on dit à
une heure et demie d'un côté 30 minutes
de l'autre c'est pas comme le barbecue
hein
c'est pas pour les en retard non non
c'est vraiment pas pour les gens pressés
deux heures de cuisson Mariano veut en
profiter pour me faire le tour de
propriétaire pour rejoindre les écuries
il faut emprunter un nouveau véhicule
on peut vite se perdre si on connaît pas
l'endroit les voisins les plus proches
sont hors du champ de vision
ici on est dans mes écuries là où je
garde mes chevaux
[Musique]
Marionnaud dépend une partie de sa
fortune dans sa passion le polo
plus ils sont petits et mieux c'est ils
sont plus nerveux et ils peuvent se
faufiler entre les autres facilement et
vous avez combien de chevaux
ici j'en ai 16 mais j'en ai d'autres sur
mes terres
en touchant les 25
[Musique]
mais puissant parfait pour la pampa
c'est le cheval du caoutchouc décrit au
jour de Marionnaud coûte environ 6000
euros pièce une fortune en Argentine
[Rires]
dans ces grands espaces si vous n'avez
pas de garde de sécurité vous vous
faites cambrioler mais oui peut-être pas
de manière violente mais ils viennent
quand vous n'êtes pas là ou même il vous
attendent pour vous surprendre à
l'entrée
ça c'est sûr même en dehors de la ville
les riches portanos savent que leur
fortune peuvent attirer les convoitises
montrez-moi un petit peu comment
s'organise la sécurité de la maison
l'extérieur
[Musique]
déjà il y a le garde là-bas dont je vous
ai parlé vous voulez parler de la
patrouille en fait oui la patrouille
j'ai aussi des caméras à chaque angle
des bâtiments et je peux consulter les
images sur mon téléphone et sur mes
ordinateurs donc vous avez une caméra
ici oui une autre là une caméra ici une
caméra là là-bas aussi à chaque fois en
fait et les vitres sont entiers fraction
ah oui elles sont à l'épreuve des balles
et vous avez une panique
en fait toute cette partie de la maison
est une panique room
voilà l'entrée de la panique room une
fois fermé on est en sécurité
et j'ai mis des barreaux en acier aux
fenêtres donc il faudrait les scier pour
pouvoir entrer ce qui est vraiment très
rare
enfin vous allez quand même mis des
barreaux peuvent être
au cas où
la viande est prête la sado est une
institution ça n'attend pas c'est le
moment de passer à table
installez-vous et je m'assois
île de la femme de Mariano est
norvégienne elle a quitté Oslo l'une des
villes les plus sûrs du monde pour vivre
à Buenos Aires
[Musique]
et comment vous vous sentez ici vous
vous sentez en sécurité vous avez peur
je ne me sens pas vraiment en danger
mais je suis plus attentif que dans les
rues d'Oslo
vous ne portez pas d'armes non il n'est
pas d'armes dans la maison non pourquoi
non non personne parce que c'est une
très mauvaise idée d'utiliser une arme
chez vous qu'est-ce que vous faites
je donne tout l'argent et je coopère si
vous utilisez une arme le voleur va
dégainer en premier il pensera que vous
êtes un flic et va vous tirer dessus à
chaque fois qu'un propriétaire est tué
dans un cambriolage il a résisté avec
une arme
lorsqu'ils sont retranchés dans leur
Barrio privado Mariano et sa famille
passent leur temps à s'entraîner au polo
[Musique]
allez-y Antoine qui est parti de polo ça
c'est du 53 ça c'est très important
c'est bon est-ce que je suis prêt
allez on y va
pas facile de se lancer dans la patrie
des meilleurs joueurs au monde où le
polo se pratique parfois dès le plus
jeune âge
[Musique]
c'est dur hein
d'habitude je suis plutôt à l'aise sur
un cheval mais je n'ai pas de maillot
dans la main
[Musique]
super encore parfait
ouais bravo
[Musique]
les cris aux choses peuvent atteindre
rapidement 70 km heure
[Musique]
fini le dimanche dans la pampa retour à
Buenos Aires mon séjour touche à sa fin
j'ai connu la violence des stades celle
des bidonvilles mais il y en a une autre
plus sourde qu'il me reste à comprendre
la violence que les dictatures
militaires ont imprimé sur le pays
[Musique]
en Argentine la dernière et la plus
féroce dictature a pris fin il y a 30
ans mais ce terrorisme d'État continue
de hanter les esprits des portaignos
face au palais présidentiel je rejoins
les maires de la Place de Mai
comme tous les jeudis donc les maires de
la place de mail se sont réunis et elles
vont commencer une procession la ronce
qui s'appelle la Rwanda et égrainer tous
les noms des disparus pendant la
dictature
une ronde pour contourner à l'époque
l'interdiction de se rassembler car
depuis le 30 avril 77 ces femmes n'ont
jamais cessé de tourner en rond chaque
jeudi elle bat le pavé pour exiger la
vérité sur le sort de leurs enfants
disparus elles sont le symbole de la
résistance au tortionnaire
les détenus disparus c'est une
expression horrible cette expression
elle n'existait pas elle n'avait pas de
sens à l'époque
disparu on s'est juste comment ils ont
fini
la plupart d'entre eux ont été jetés
dans la mer depuis des avions
et les autres sont morts sous la torture
[Musique]
Buenos Aires le 24 mars 76 un coup
d'État militaire fait tomber la
présidente d'Argentine Isabelle Péronne
le général Videla prend le pouvoir et
installe une politique de la terreur ces
méthodes sont brutales le moindre pesant
régime de la jante et systématiquement
traqué torturé et assassiné
une férocité sans limite
c'est lui qui met en place les fameux
vols de la mort
c'était là au-dessus du Rio de la Plata
que les prisonniers étaient jetés dans
le vide depuis un avion militaire
entre 1976 et 1983 environ 30 000
personnes disparaissent et 500 000
argentins quittent le pays
pendant longtemps évoquer les disparus
de la dictature a été un sujet tabou
mais en 2003 les lois d'admistie qui
protégeaient les bourreaux ont été
supprimés depuis l'Argentine n'en finit
pas de découvrir les horreurs de la
dictature
dans le quartier haussmannien de onsay à
Buenos Aires difficile d'imaginer qu'au
premier étage de cet immeuble une équipe
d'anthropologues légistes assemble tibia
fémur vertèbre et crâne
ici vous êtes dans le laboratoire de
l'équipe argentine d'anthropologie
médico-légal il a été créé il y a 30 ans
dans le but d'identifier les restes de
personnes disparues lors de la dernière
dictature
l'équipe d'anthropologues législent de
Louise et l'une des plus réputées au
monde leur expertise dans
l'identification de cadavres les a
conduits dans une quarantaine de pays
Bosnie Salvador Tchad Chili ces
anthropologues globroteurs ont aussi
identifié les ossements de Che Guevara
assassiné en Bolivie en ce moment Louise
est en train d'identifier trois
squelettes de disparu de la dictatures
retrouvées dans un charnier sa mission
consiste également à reconstituer les
dernières minutes avant leur mort
montrez-nous le travail que vous faites
sur les ossements qu'est-ce que vous
faites qu'on les recevez ici quand on
reçoit les restes en détermine l'âge le
sexe la corpulence et on obtient ainsi
un profil biologique
après on essaie d'analyser les chocs sur
les eaux
et vous voyez les blessures oui dans ce
cas vous pouvez voir l'entrée de la
balle ici et
la sortie de l'autre côté là
ici on a une fracture importante au
visage à la fin avec les analyses
scientifiques du squelette on a une
vision plus précise de ce qui s'est
passé et c'est ce qu'on transmet aux
familles et au tribunal chargés de ses
affaires
la plupart des gens sont tués par balle
mais beaucoup d'autres on ne sait pas
combien exactement ont été jetés depuis
les avions dans la mer et dans le Rio de
la Plata et dans ce cas la personne
mourait à cause du choc sur l'eau
[Musique]
depuis l'avion pensait qu'ils étaient
morts et après qu'il est déjà jeté
non non ils étaient bien vivants
à ce jour lui c'est son équipe ont
identifié 620 personnes disparues
pendant la dictature
[Applaudissements]
direction lesma l'école de mécanique
marine
l'indécente de torture les plus
emblématiques du pays une version
argentine de la Gestapo au cœur de
Buenos Aires
enlevez clandestinements 5000 personnes
ont été détenues dans ce centre avant
d'être exécuté
et la barbarie des militaires ne
s'arrête pas là
[Musique]
lorsqu'il vient à l'ESMA Guillermo n'est
pas très à l'aise
d'ailleurs il préfère t'accompagner de
l'os elle connaît tout de l'organisation
de cette usine à fabriquer des morts
les voitures arrivaient jusqu'ici et
s'arrêtaient dans cette cour les
prisonniers étaient extraits des
voitures et emmenés directement dans les
caves où se trouvaient les salles de
torture parce que la première chose qui
leur arrivait quand on les amenait ici
c'était d'être interrogé sous la torture
ici les militaires ont aussi séquestré
des femmes enceintes qu'il faisait
accoucher clandestinement avant de les
assassiner et de s'approprier leur bébé
Guillermo et l'un de ses bébés volés
sous le dictature
j'arrive j'ai besoin de respirer un peu
là
allez on y va
Guillermo est né en détention au fond de
cette cave
être ici dans cette cave c'est pas
facile
donc il faut prendre de l'élan c'est
comme quand tu vas aller sous l'eau il
faut prendre une bonne respiration voilà
c'est pareil
il faut que tu comprennes que dans cet
endroit la cinquième fenêtre exactement
là-bas
c'est là que ma mère m'a mis au monde
exactement comme un animal le ferait en
captivité dans un zoo tu vois
déjà dans le ventre j'étais privé de
liberté
Guillermo a vu le jour sous cette
fenêtre le 15 novembre 1978 dans la même
cave ont été pratiqué les tortures à sa
naissance il est séparé de sa mère
les militaires le donnent un employé de
l'Armée de l'Air impliqué dans les vols
de la mort
Guillermo grandit dans une famille
d'adoption proche des torchères de ses
parents sans jamais connaître sa
véritable identité en 2004 un coup de
fil anonyme le met sur une piste en pro
au doute Guillermo questionne de plus en
plus son père adoptif mis sous pression
il lui avoue tout
j'apprends tout d'un coup que je suis
fils de disparu que mes parents
participaient à la lutte armée que ma
mère était juive et étudiante en
médecine que mon père a été torturé et
beaucoup t'imagines j'étais en train de
conduire et j'apprends que je ne suis
pas celui que je crois que la personne
assise à côté de moi ce n'est pas mon
père et qu'en plus il a participé à la
disparition de mon vrai père ça fait
beaucoup d'infos d'un seul coup
[Musique]
bourg guirmo un monde s'écroule et
laisse place à une deuxième naissance il
a 21 ans et porte plainte contre son
père adoptif qui sera condamné à 8 ans
de prison
aujourd'hui 400 bébés volés devenus des
adultes vivent encore sans connaître
leur véritable identité
mon séjour touche à sa fin mais j'ai
envie de rester encore un peu à lesmar
cet endroit est bouleversant un lieu de
torture transformé aujourd'hui en lieu
de mémoire bonjour
NASA est un artiste très connu au Buenos
Aires pourtant il ne montre jamais son
visage c'est un peu le Daft Punk du
pinceau plutôt que sa personne il veut
mettre en avant ses œuvres
de cette personne est une mer
emblématique de la Place de Mai c'est
verra j'ai trouvé que cette image était
très forte et qu'elle avait sa place ici
son regard est très expressif
NASA veut m'aider à mieux saisir
l'atmosphère qui règne ici il est né lui
aussi sous le dictature il est de la
même génération que Guillermo
on doit à NASA une dizaine de pochoirs
sur les murs de l'ESMA les œuvres qui
évoquent les drames qui se sont
déroulées ici
ici c'est une fille qui tient la photo
de sa grand-mère disparue ça représente
en quelque sorte le combat des parents
disparu qui continue grâce aux enfants
les militaires ont séquestré les gens
les ont torturé et les ont assassiné on
les jetés des avions on les fusillait
sans aucun cadre légal et le slogan
justice et Châtiment rappelle que nous
demandons justice mais dans un cadre
légal que n'ont jamais donné à leur
victime pourquoi beaucoup d'Argentins
comme vous comme les les maires de la
Place de Mai sont toujours très
présentes et très active pour ce devoir
de mémoire
tu sais tout ça est encore très présent
il y a encore beaucoup de problèmes qui
nous touchent aujourd'hui on souffre
encore des conséquences de tout ça on
trouve encore des vestiges parmi les
forces de sécurité dans toutes les
forces de police chez les militaires
c'est quelque chose qu'on vit encore
aujourd'hui
et tant que l'on garde tout ça dans le
présent c'est une façon pour nous
d'empêcher que ça se reproduise
les pochoirs de NASA effaceront pas les
traces de l'horreur
au contraire ils sont une arme contre
l'amnésie
cette nouvelle génération de porter une
osme me plaît c'est comme une promesse
de jours meilleurs à Buenos Aires
la fin de l'immunité et la
multiplication des procès envoie
progressivement les bourreaux en prison
avec l'état d'urgence Buenos Aires tente
d'enrayer sa violence la police embauche
et traque série pour
mais je ne quitte pas Buenos Aires
complètement rassuré le pays est une
fois de plus en faillite ce qui rend ces
efforts de réforme et de justice
bien fragile
[Musique]